over the course of eight years President
Obama was shadowed by former White House
photographer Pete Souza his photos
captured nearly every moment during the
44th presidents two terms Souza
sometimes took 2000 photos a day his new
book Obama an intimate portrait features
more than 300 photos he takes readers
behind the scenes with President Obama
Pete Souza good morning thank you for
having me it's a beautiful book it's
really well done and I love the foreword
by the former president who says I
probably spent more time with Pete Souza
than anybody other than my family in the
eight years in the White House you were
a constant presence and chronicler of
history I was it was a great privilege
to do this job I feel fortunate that I
had the opportunity this is as good a
picture I've ever seen I think
photograph but do you have one that you
think defies or sort of portrays the
president more than any other single
photograph here that captures him you
know I saw him in so many walks of life
that it's hard to choose any one
certainly some of the one of him
interacting with kids or with his family
but also the more weighty pictures of
him in the Situation Room
during the bin Laden raid so there's I
think the pictures together tell you the
most about him in any one picture well
you certainly got to see the variety of
him you got to see a sense of humor I
love the one page 102 where his foot is
on the scale of someone who works with
him and everybody he clearly was playing
a joke on the guy and everybody was in
on the joke
yeah Marvin Nicholson was he was
checking his way because he had been
trying to try to wait and he kept
sliding the the scale to the right and
I'm he notes to him the president's got
his toe on the scale that was funny
you've got hecklers backstage I thought
that was interesting that you're the
president is speaking and he's heckled
but he calls the hecklers backstage so
if you guys must have freaked about that
he it was an immigration policy speech
and there were these two guys that were
heckling him during his speech and he
said let me finish my speech and then
after
where do you come backstage and I'll
have a private conversation view and
that's exactly what he did
and you see The Secret Service agent
there were there ever moments and I know
the president praised you for being
almost invisible he didn't know
sometimes you're in there were there
ever moments where you thought this is
too personal I I shouldn't be here or
there shouldn't be a photograph of this
moment not when it came to moments of
history with moments with the family yes
I would try to give him space moments of
history I felt you know I am the guy
that needs to be there for everything
that happens so in those cases know Jim
Baker has said about being Secretary of
State you really have to have the
complete trust of the president this is
the same thing prevent photography yes
absolutely have to have that
relationship salutely and I think well I
think you earn it over time I mean I was
lucky in that I had known him for four
years before he became president had
already established the professional
relationship with him so coming in I
already knew him that helped but then
over time you just have to earn that
trust day in and day out one of the most
famous photos that I know was displayed
in the White House for a long time was
of a young boy touching President
Obama's hair my favorite photo yes that
one that photo became so iconic because
why oh I think for two reasons one the
little boy's name is Jacob Philadelphia
he's touching the the man who's the
president and he looks like him but it
also tells you something about President
Obama where he would be willing to bend
over like that and let a four-year-old
just touches touch his head
you said of that picture say your hair
is just like your hair is just like mine
that's why I think that photo is so
beautiful and you said of all the
pictures that stayed up the longest
normally you take them down and you
recycle them but that one kept coming
back notice people wanted that to see
then I just we took it down at one point
and I had
individual staff members come into my
office asking me to put it back up I
love all the pictures of the president
with it with it with children him with a
super soaker gun we have a picture
that's a very private moment he's
clearly with the family I think it was
in camp days at Camp David running
around the pool squirting Sasha yeah I
thought that would like to be there in
the Situation Room when they're watching
the Obama Ben love scene in London yeah
the the thing that I like to tell people
about that photograph is you have the
most powerful people in the federal
government watching as this is unfolding
and really there's nothing they can do
they've already made their decision and
now it's up to those guys on the ground
and I think that's what leads to the
anxiety and all those phases but I love
the back story you told about that Pete
they just said we need you to be here at
such-and-such time you didn't know what
was going to happen he said it's a very
small room and you just you said I have
to get in a corner and just stay and you
were trying to figure out which corner
should I be in who tells you that the
chief of staff no I had about a week's
notice that something was gonna be
unfolding I was actually someone in
John's brennan's office that alerted me
so I knew it was going to be on that
Sunday and it was actually you know we
were there all day
yeah it wasn't just that one 40-minute
meeting in that little room but there
were meetings throughout the day what's
your takeaway of the man who knew him
before he was president while he was
president and then after what's your
takeaway of Barack Obama right my
takeaway is you know I met him his first
day in the Senate in 2005 that was the
first time they ever ever met him and I
obviously still know him today I don't
think the core of his character has
changed one iota
I really don't what's the essence of
taking a good picture it's capturing a
moment but accurately portraying the
mood and the emotion that's taking place
seeing it coming yes
you know if you were invisible in some
ways as the president says before but
now you've taken a more visible role and
on Instagram I noticed that you in the
words of some younger people they say
you troll president Trump why I mean I
think the the photographs that
I post on Instagram now and the words
that I write I think speak for
themselves right Pete Souza thank you
very much
yeah your pictures that your words say a
lot I love watching your Instagram thank
you sir for joining us through the
speech the name of the book is Obama an
intimate portrait it's on sale tomorrow
wherever you like to buy your books